Robert Downey jr. has been kicking
around Hollywood for a long time he
survived a devastating drug addiction
only to emerges one of the biggest stars
in the world thanks to his role as Tony
Stark in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but he's still just an actor and he
screws up on set just like every other
actor in Hollywood here I sometimes when
the lovable Robert Downey jr. was even
more engaging because of onset mishaps
pucker up kissing scenes can't be easy
needing to performers to take their
on-screen chemistry to the next level
and physically show their characters
affection by kissing is awkward weird
wet and silly it can even feel odd for
veteran top-notch professionals who've
worked with each other before
just ask winneth Paltrow and Robert
Downey jr. in this outtake Tony Stark
and Pepper Potts are about to separate
for a lengthy period of time and the two
characters kiss
well they try fine suits me - Downey
makes light of his embarrassment by
specifically calling out their goof for
what it is silent treatment being a
leader usually affords a person power
and glory but there are also some
drawbacks like an unrelenting sense of
responsibility in this scene Robert
Downey jr. --hz Tony Stark attempts to
explain the gravity of a situation to
Chris Hemsworth's
Thor but Hemsworth doesn't seem to care
or can't remember how to the larger
center this it is what we need
you're gonna leave me here with an on
what on my face again I'm gonna start it
let's go back got it covered movie sets
are highly pressurized places and actors
can spend all day doing take after take
the same scene that's a recipe for
exhaustion which itself is a recipe for
silliness actors can look at one another
the wrong way and erupt in a fit of
giggles requiring them to take it from
the top and try again but Robert Downey
jr. doesn't even need another actor to
trigger a laughing jag we always cover
the ass less than civil Captain America
Civil Wars most notable contribution to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is its
introduction of spider-man portrayed by
relative newcomer Tom Holland Ironman
also earns a lot of screen time giving
fans another opportunity to bask in the
glory of Robert Downey jr. and while
Holland it's just off screen and
apparently doing something he's not
supposed to be doing these sometimes
boastful but always self-deprecating
Robert Downey jr. can't take the
distraction Tom Chambers on me now
getting down the Avengers aren't all
just about saving the world and universe
from agents of evil and selfishness now
they also like to plan strategize and
pump themselves up for the task at hand
that goes for the cast too in this
outtake from age of Ultron Captain
America Thor and Tony Stark have a
little bonding moment over their shared
love of dancing of course you like to
get down right that's just Cathy gonna
bring it suppose I'll have to
[Music]
suit up there are a lot of names and
jargon to remember in comic book based
movies it's even hard for Robert Downey
jr. who probably knows the ins and outs
of Marvel better than any other actor on
the planet by now for the end of Iron
Man 3 Stark must call upon a slew of
different super-powered suits of armor
there are a lot of them and while their
inventor and operator can certainly
rattle them off Downey can't heart
breaker will you help what's his name
snapper thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all the school
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]